this is how you make General Tso chicken
wings
we have our chicken wings I'm just gonna
season this with kosher salt and garlic
powder all right let's make the seasoned
flour flour and our mix of seasonings
mix that well all right to make our
batter flour egg and water mix that
until it's very smooth okay now it's
time to fry we have plain flour throw in
the wings just a light coating of flour
dip in our batter also keep a light
coating then the seasoned flour
give it a good squeeze now immediately
fry your chicken
now that is a sexy wing all right now
let's make the sauce medium heat add
some oil Ginger
dried chilies
garlic cook it for about 30 seconds
you're going to add the water
scrape the bottom of the pan get all
that flavor and we're gonna add oyster
sauce then some sugar white vinegar add
your cornstarch slurry
now paint your Masterpiece now that is a
beautiful wing